Gordon stood alone in the hall.
He hadn't heard the bell to go inside.
He had to go to music class, but he didn't know where to go.
Gordon was a new kid at school.
He knew the music room wasn't on the first floor.
His classroom was on the first floor.
So, Gordon went up the stairs.
He knew he had to hurry.
His teacher would be worried.
At the top of the stairs, Gordon turned right down the hall.
On the left, he saw a door.
It might be the music room, he thought.
No, it was the art room.
Gordon asked the teacher,...
..."Do you know where the music room is?"
"Sure."
The teacher said.
"Turn right out of this room. Go past the stairs. On your left, you'll see a door like this one. That is the music room."
Gordon thanked her and hurried down the hall.
Gordon's teacher, Mr. Lewis, was outside the music room.
"There you are!"
Mr. Lewis said.
"Mr. Green asked me to find you."
Gordon smiled.
"I found you first!"